one of the skills that you need to pick
up very quickly as a consultant is
project management as a consultant you
regularly work in large organizations
on topics covering many functions and
business units it is the responsibility
of the project lead in the consulting
team to set up a governance structure to
set up some project management best
practices to make sure that the whole
team stays organized and can deliver on
the things that the team needs to
deliver on hi guys
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel firm learning my name is
heinrich and on this channel i want to
help you to become successful in the
first
years of your career in today's video
i'm going to show you in detail how at
mbb consulting firms the consultants
keep the whole project
organized how they organize their shared
drives how they
archive and make files available to the
whole team before we jump into the video
i want to take an opportunity to say
thank you to all the sponsors of this
channel you're really helping me to
bring this channel alive this is much
appreciated
if you want to become a member as well
and get access to some great perks
sign up via the join button below
there's also a link in the video
description it would mean the world to
me if you become a member of this
channel but now let's
jump into the topic and how do
consultants stay organized
consulting firms usually use some type
of shared drive
service provider so whether it's box
dropbox onedrive or anything related
there's going to be a platform
where all your files for a project are
going to stay so let's start with the
overarching folder
how do you name it and here a beginner
mistake that some people do is that they
name the folder the same as
the client's name so they give the
folder the name of the company that you
are currently working for here the big
risk that you want to avoid is that at
some point you're sitting together in a
meeting with clients now your screen is
shared and you need to pull out a file
and now your explorer pops up and now
there is a list of all the folders with
all your client names that you're
currently working for you worked for in
the past of course this would be a major
breach of confidentiality you do not
reveal your client names to other
companies so make sure that your client
folders for your overarching folder
structure are not
named in the company way but give it
some kind of a more cryptic
name some more cryptic abbreviation that
you lose internally so that if your
explorer window pops up in front of your
client that all your client names are
not revealed so how do you organize and
structure the next
level of data within your folder and now
i'm going to show you a typical
structure
and i used variations of that many times
of course the details can always depend
a bit on the needs of the individual
projects but if you follow this usually
this will be already a very solid
structure so first of all you will see
that on the left of each subfolder you
use numbers to keep them in the right
order if you just give them a name then
they will usually be ordered
alphabetically and then this can be a
mess because often of course the best
order is not the alphabet but another
order that you
define so give numbers and use at least
two digits because often you will have
more than 10 folders so use numbers to
make sure that the folders always stay
in the order that you want them to stay
so what would be typical folders that
you'd like to have on this
first level so often i'd like to start
with an admin folder so this is the
folder where you put all kinds of
admin documents in so for instance
timesheets for your team
maybe some other overviews that
everybody needs access to
some travel information just admin
documents where everybody needs to have
an easy access on next you set up two
different types of meeting folders
one for internal meetings and one for
client meetings so in the internal
meeting folder you then archive all the
meetings that you have with your partner
with your team all the internal things
and then the client folder as the name
says all the interactions where you then
have meetings with your clients
next you will have a folder for the
initial data request and here
not on every project but in many
projects before you actually start you
will submit a list of data that you
asked the client to prepare to make sure
that once you're there once you are
working on the client that you already
have at least most of the things you
need to enable you to hit the ground
running this is often important
based data that the whole team needs
access to so you make sure that you have
this neatly collected in this
overarching folder next you will have a
folder each for the key work streams or
modules of your project usually when you
set up a project you divide
it into different sub-streams into
different modules into different work
streams and then often you
assign each associate to one of these
modules in this specific example you
work for different
business units of the clients so for an
energy business unit for an automotive
business unit and for an advanced
industries business unit these folders
will be owned by the associates of your
team working on the individual modules
and this is where all the modules
specific where all the work stream
specific content suits for your project
next you will have some folders for the
big overarching analysis that you are
doing for some work stream overarching
some module overarching topics that your
team is working on
in this specific example there was an
employee survey where apparently the
employees of the clients were surveyed
in this folder you could now organize
the survey and where you could then save
all the survey results in addition there
seemed to have happened an overarching
benchmark where different functions of
the client were benchmarked and again
then you can set up a folder like this
where you organize it next you have a
folder with input from your research
team
and first of all notice how the first
number of this folder is a nine so by
giving it a nine you make sure that it
always stays at the bottom of your
folder structure
so you do this to keep these a bit less
important folders always at the bottom
to not mess up the whole order so in
such a research input folder you can
collect all the inputs that you get from
your research team so in many large
consulting firms you will have back
offices that help you to do some
research
such a folder would be the place where
you organize all this then you might
have a folder for old documents maybe
there was already a project going on
before you and i just take all the data
and just put it in one folder so you
have it available if you still need it
at some point in the future and then
finally you will often use a folder for
final deliverables where you then over
time organize or the final documents
that you will hand over to the client at
the very end of your project so let's
now go one level deeper on the meeting
folders because these are indeed some
folders that are usually heavily used
and it's quite important to have a solid
order here
the first thought is here that every
meeting you have should be documented in
these folders so if you wonder okay what
document did i show
two weeks ago when i sat together with
this guy you should always be able to go
back in your folder structure and find
the very specific document that then you
want to pull out and what i learned and
what i can really recommend you is to
always then make the folder start with
the date when the meeting
actually took place and here again make
sure that you start with the year
then the month and then the day because
this makes sure that if you order them
then the meetings will always show up
chronologically as they actually took
place and often it makes sense to
include what type of meeting it is and
often also with whom you had the meeting
so for the internal meeting folder this
can for instance be a team kickoff a
team offside maybe some meetings or
calls you had with partners of yours as
this list of folders can easily grow and
can get
quite large at some point then it can
often make sense then just to put
together all the meetings in one month
or monthly folder so at some point you
can just drag all the meetings in july
into a july folder all the meetings in
august into an august folder then you
just have all the detailed lists just
for the current month we then might need
to more grainily look into the meetings
for the clients it's very similar here
you might typically have draw fixes you
might have steer close you might have
other client meetings like that if
you're interested to learn more how such
a typical work week in the life of an
mbb consultant looks like
also check out the video that i will
insert here somewhere above to better
understand how exactly these meetings
will play out during a typical work week
now another little best practice tip
that i want to give you is now to
organize the documents within these
specific meeting folders so if you work
together
on a team on such a document often then
this folder can easily look like this
right so a whole lot of
versions and often if you work on such
documents like the big stir code
documents over some time with your team
the list of documents can easily look
like a mess like this so with lots of
different versions
lots of different iterations and at some
point it can get super
difficult for somebody looking at it to
understand what now really the latest
version is now especially if you put
yourself into the shoes of for instance
a partner he just wants to access the
drive
just go into the meeting fold and just
quickly pull out the latest version of
this theoko document that actually was
shown right just to look something up
and for him now if he sees something
like this this is really a nightmare
because he doesn't know what now the
latest version was he pretty much needs
to always call up the team and ask hey
guys okay what is now the latest version
right i don't understand anything at all
anymore so here it's the best practice
than to have such an
old folder but then you drag all the
older versions in
and make sure that in the meetings
folder you really only have the latest
version of your documents the latest and
hopefully final version that then
everybody knows okay this is really the
document that we need to look in another
little best practice is also to clearly
label the documents by the status of the
release right so if you send out the
document to the client then distinctly
save it as
a vcent or something related if you then
present the document distinctly save it
as a
v presented or then maybe if you make
changes afterwards save it as a v
final but this will enable you if they
really wanna know okay what was the
version that i
sent out what was the version that i
really presented what was
the version with some last changes and
maybe even did after the meeting that
all of this is always clearly labeled
clearly saved this can really save you
some significant headache if then later
somebody asks you about a specific
version that you're just not able to
understand anymore which of the version
numbers it was right so clearly always
save it with these labels you really
thank me in the long term if you do that
so that's it guys these are now my best
practices so i believe you should
organize and structure your project and
what for sure is the best practice in
large mbb consulting firms hope you
found this insightful and if you have
any more questions feel free to leave me
a comment below in the comment section
as
always i will do my very best to answer
every single one if you took any value
out of this video at all please destroy
the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe to my
channel for even more content i release
weekly videos every saturday so
subscribe to stay up to date if you want
to see even more from me
follow me on instagram my handle is firm
learning and i also have a mailing list
if you want to sign up for that there's
a link in the video description for
access to some more great perks that
only members get sign up as a member
there is a join button next to the
subscription button and also in the
video description and yes you will get
access to some member
only perks thank you for watching and
your support this really means the world
to me
thank you guys i'm heine from from
learning and see you again
next saturday bye